[Music]
hello everybody it's good to be here
obviously I live I'm actually from New
Jersey exactly I went to Rutgers
University the State University of New
Jersey their slogan is don't finish it's
not gonna make a difference and I was an
English major which prepares you for two
things in life you can teach English or
be a dick at parties I believe you meant
to say whom ate all the guacamole twas I
I don't even know if that's right I went
to Rutgers then I moved to New York City
I lived in Chinatown New York City I
don't have you guys have been there but
the fun thing about Chinatown New York
City is that there are no rules you can
break laws willy-nilly and no one's
watching the store if you see a police
officer there he's doing bad stuff too
he doesn't want to see you either you
could literally drag a body on a tarp
into Chinatown and four dudes run up and
they're like $10 you're like are you
giving me $10 or am i giving you $10
this is a punch card I will be back sir
by the way sorry if you don't know what
Chinatown is if you're from the middle
of the country Chinatown is when a bunch
of Chinese people come to your city and
they look around and they're like yeah
we're not doing that and they just build
China in the middle of your city
and everybody that already lives there
is like I guess we'll eat ducks so then
I moved to Los Angeles I'm here now
that has not been my experience I've
been here for two years haven't made one
new friend I don't look inside I blame
you
here's a it's hard to meet normal people
in Los Angeles is a real experience I
had I was at a party and this guy goes
hey man you're really funny this is my
friend he's a model / DJ I was like whoa
one man can be two nothing's so now I
just stay home I don't really go out
here much I do shows you know I stay
home I watch TV now what's the best show
on TV guys best show on TV
wrong it's jeopardy everybody jeopardy
is the best show on television how
ironic that you got it wrong
jeopardy is amazing I think it's my
favorite show because by the way
whatever show you just said I have proof
jeopardy as a better show your show will
be gone one day jeopardy is here forever
no matter what mostly because they have
a perpetually renewable resource which
is three new contestants every night who
are great at trivia mostly because they
haven't had a conversation with another
human being in like six or seven years
and Alex knows that these people are on
the social disorder spectrum because
he's like so what words do you think is
a story and they're like I have a cat
and then I come home and my cat says hi
he's like okay you're gonna be great at
this game but my favorite thing happened
not too long ago it was amazing some
contestant did something I didn't know
you could do on that show Alex go she
goes I'll take television for 1,200 Alex
and he goes this mode of transportation
killed Charlie Sheen's character in Two
and a Half Men and she rings in and I'm
not exaggerating her answer she goes
I don't care what's a bus I didn't know
you could do that I didn't know you
could share your feelings on Jeopardy
she spent twelve hundred dollars of her
own money just to let America know she
didn't care about two and a half men and
if you lose money on that show you could
end up with negative money but you don't
have to pay jeopardy back if you're bad
at it you know what I mean if you're
negative five grand Alex doesn't come to
your house the next day like are we
gonna have a situation so you could be
smart enough to get on Jeopardy not need
the money at all ring in first after
every single clue no matter what and
just share your opinions with America
and nobody can stop you I feel like I'll
take South America for 1,200 Alex like
this is the longest river in South
America and I'd be like oh and that
chatting Tatum so hot I could have sex
live and I'm not gay and he'd be like
that's incorrect and I'd be like is it
Alex
[Applause]
great
Larry thank you very nice job thank you
killing the power let's have a baby like
God